good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is the customer is king over to
you Gordon Ramsay key to a successful
business is remembering that customers
King because without them we're nobody
and so I from a chef's point of view
always put myself in a customer's
situation where I see it from their eyes
I don't cook for chefs
every time chefs come into the dining
room the first thing to do is turn up
the place upside down start
photographing the food and they're
constantly you know dissecting the food
as a time as opposed to enjoying it so I
always look at from a customer's
perspective because they're king and
without them we're history so when I
first took over trying to dance salsa
just over a year ago almost two years
ago how long has it been Alex it's in
January January last year and it's it's
August so yeah wow it's been a while so
I took over Toronto dance salsa and I
sat down with Alex I hired Alex away
from his full-time job to work at
Toronto dance salsa and I said okay how
we gonna grow this business here are 10
ways that we can grow our business I
gave him a list of 10 things that he
could do because if you try to do all 10
things you're gonna suck at all of them
I think we try to do that as
entrepreneurs we try to do everything
and then nothing gets done properly and
so we had 10 things on our list 10 ways
to market our business and to grow it he
had to pick two now why not pick for him
one was being a thought leader one was
sharing content when was sharing his
opinions being on snapchat being the
leader making videos that had to be part
of the plan if you're gonna work under
me if we're gonna create this
relationship but I'm gonna mentor you
being a thought leader has to be a part
of it that's why I ALS's in some of the
videos we've seen oh and espresso this
you know in seven ways I seen him a lot
the second way you pick pick the thing
that resonates the most with you and the
one that he picked was having a
remarkable customer experience so that
anytime somebody came into our studio
or anybody somebody visit our website or
wrote into our our team or tried to call
us they would have an amazing customer
experience because if the customer loves
the service they love the experience
they're going to come back they're going
to be more loyal and they're gonna tell
their friends and so we made the
decision to invest our resources our
time our energy our dollars on how do we
make the experience better for our
customers and that extends everything
that we do in the business so it's not
just about the service that we provide
right people come here and they want to
learn dance classes great you want to
give them a good experience right so
they're in class they're learning the
steps they're learning the moves great
understanding why they came here trying
to tap into the deeper reason and then
give them a better experience that hits
the core of why they signed up in the
first place
most people don't come trying to learn
dance moves they're coming because they
need a break from their crappy life they
hate their job they're trying to meet
somebody they just broke up with
somebody you know they're looking for
some new friends it's a thing to do and
I want to turn the business from not
just being something that is a thing to
do the cross off your bucket list but
something that actually has a meaningful
lasting long-term impact on the lives of
our customers so you then expand it out
through the entire chain of a lifetime
of a customer so when do they first
write in to us or do they call in to us
how is that first conversation going
right what can be better but the email
that we respond to or how can we pick up
the phone faster give them a better
experience on the phone you know then
they come to the class and then what
happens after class what happens in
between the classes and so using the
lens right this is how we look at our
customers look at our business how do we
create a more remarkable experience you
can go through every little step every
little touch point every little
interaction that a customer has with us
and a customer has with you you can find
a way to make it better and think of it
not just as providing a great service or
providing a great product not just
giving them what they paid for but the
experience in dealing with you has to be
amazing
so an example one of the things when one
phone call people have questions there's
a lot of the standard same questions but
it's not just about answering their
questions and being friendly but it's
always looking for a way to over-deliver
if you understand their why that
signing up why they're interested it's
looking for something now so you can
offer at the end after answering the
questions that can be that extra bonus
for them where they leave with their
life and their day feeling better
because of the interaction they had with
us and so if you look at your experience
look at every touch point you have with
your customer think about how you cannot
just provide them with the answers not
just provide them with a great solution
that solves their problem but the entire
experience of dealing with your
customers is not just a pleasant
positive one but as an outstanding one
but they want to rave about their
friends so that they can't wait to come
back and deal with you again and they
want to spread the mission spread the
word for you
so the question day today is I'm curious
what is something that you do to really
wow your customers above and beyond just
giving them a great product or service
I'd love to hear from you maybe learn
something as well that I could apply to
my businesses leave it down in the
comments below
also if you have a comment within the
first couple hours you have a chance to
win one of our two daily prizes I also
want to give a quick shout out to Neil
curd Neil thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
making that youtube video and posting it
online I really appreciate this
apartment and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed my book thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso
[Music]
I used to work for Warren Davis the guy
who started Avis rent-a-car and he sets
me one day Robert what's the purpose of
business and I said oh make a profit and
all these other things they said no the
purpose of business is to create a
customer because everything else takes
care of itself if you can create
customers and create value for them
because the answer that question is
different for every single customer then
you're gonna have a great business like
I'd like to sit down with founders and I
like to work on removing friction from
process whatever it might be and
creating products that are intuitive and
one of the things that I get from
working in the creative space and being
an actor is really understanding feeling
and touch and art and you know it's an
art being able to being able to create
an impulse within a consumer to do
something is an art form I could
probably give you ten or twenty examples
of companies that have really just taken
software that was archaic software that
was untouchable by consumers and
actually brought it down to a consumer
level that that is becoming the process
to making it to building a great
software company these days you can look
at a company like zenefits
it's like there's always been HR
software that's been out there in some
way shape or form or you can look at
Robin Hood and there's always been ways
that you can interface and do stock
exchanges but making it something that
that the average consumer can
intuitively understand and touch and
play with and use it and have it be
beneficial in their life is about
understanding the intuition and and the
feeling of the consumer I thought that
right now would be the perfect time to
share a customer service story with you
true story a couple years ago I got a
call from a young lady and it's all
excited she tells me she's looking for a
property and then she says the word
lease our favorite words as Realtors I'm
looking for a lease you know unless it's
an eighty five thousand dollar a month
lease hello but I was in a good mood so
I took that call and I said sure
I'll help you find a lease and turns out
it was a $5,000 month lease and I took
her around for six months
the term was only a year
anyways I like to finish what I start so
I went through with it found her an
amazing place she couldn't be happier in
fact she was so happy that she called
her father that night and she said dad I
got the greatest place my realtor is
amazing he doesn't care about money at
all and it happened to be that her
father was sitting next to the CEO of
his company and he heard the story and
that CEO said actually I'm thinking
selling my penthouse maybe I should use
that guy sure enough I went in I met the
CEO and I got the listing of his four
million dollar penthouse while I was
sitting that open house on that four
million dollar penthouse because that's
my favorite thing to do a celebrity
walked in and that celebrity walked
around and he checked out that
incredible penthouse and he looked me it
looked at me and he said yeah this is
cool do you have anything cooler I said
sure so I went back to the office and I
put together the list of the coolest
penthouses you could find and I showed
that celebrity around and that celebrity
ended up buying an 11 million dollar
penthouse which broke the record for
Santa Monica so from that lease that
$5,000 a month lease which led to that
four million dollar penthouse sale which
led to that 11 million dollar penthouse
sale and it is the gift that keeps on
giving
on and on and on that is why customer
service is so important to everybody's
business